Hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel. My camera fell off the grip
that it was on for probably the last 2
and 1/2 years. And uh now I went ahead
and moved it which is why you can see
this absolutely brand new stunning angle
of me. Please don't dox me based on the
ever so slightly additional information
you see in the back of my apartment.
Today we're going to be talking about
how to build Facebook Messenger, which
is a very big skill every single
software engineer should have because it
makes you three times as effective in
the DM. For me personally, that went
from 0% success rate to 0% success rate.
But uh my point still holds true. Let's
go ahead and get into it. Facebook
Messenger and WhatsApp are both
real-time instant messaging platforms.
When a user sends a message to a chat,
all users in the chat should see it.
Messages in each chat should be
deterministically ordered. We also
expect that message delivery should take
only a couple of seconds. Group chats
are also on the table. For example, I
have a group chat with myself and all
the mils within a 10 mile radius of me.
Let's formalize our requirements here.
Users should be able to create chats,
add members to a chat, remove members
from a chat, and send messages to a
chat. In addition, they should receive
messages for all chats that they're
members of. If for some reason their
device was offline, they should receive
their missed messages when they come
back online. In my case, for example, I
turned off my phone for an hour and came
back to a thousand messages from Karina
begging for my bath water. Let's
estimate that we have a billion users
sending a 100 billion messages per day.
This equates to a bit over 1 million
messages per second. Another practical
limit that both Messenger and WhatsApp
enforce is on group chat size which they
keep to around 500. Finally, let's
assume we have 10 billion total group
chats each with 10 users on average.
Let's consider how we'll represent a
group chat. At a high level, it's just a
set of users. If we choose to take a
normalized database approach, this chat
members table has a very simple schema
of chat ID and user ID where there can
be many rows per chat ID. An individual
chat will just have two users in it.
Adding a user to a chat just requires
adding their row here and removing them
from it is the opposite.
Recall from our capacity slide, we have
10 billion group chats with on average
10 users each. Since each user ID and
chat ID can be stored with eight bytes,
each data row is 16 bytes and there
should be 100 billion rows. It costs us
1.6 terabytes to store this table. Next,
we can consider how we want to represent
messages. Each message has a sender ID,
a chat ID, a server sign, and a message
payload. There's probably also some
metadata, too, about where the message
was sent from. In total, let's imagine
this comes out to about 200 bytes. We
need to add 20 terabytes of data per day
just to accommodate 100 billion
messages. Every Messenger user needs to
receive messages from all of the group
chats that they're in. In the past, I've
suggested that we may want to do this
with a real-time push technology from a
server to the client. Options here are
things like websockets or server send
events. One possibility here would be
users connected to many application
servers. So, as the users receive
incoming messages, they can forward them
to all interested parties. However, this
is not a good idea. Since a user can be
in a bunch of different chats, they'd
potentially have to maintain many
simultaneous server connections, which
is expensive for the device. It would be
a lot better if each user just
maintained a connection to a single
server at a time to receive messages. In
the diagram on screen, client devices
now have to publish messages to many
different servers. We don't want that
either, as it puts a ton of load on the
sender device to publish so many API
requests for large group chats. Another
option would be to have the servers
perform the message routing. In this
case, we have two options. We could
return an acknowledgement back to the
sender after server 2 receives the
message, or we could return it after
both receivers have gotten the message.
In the first case, we're still prone to
failures after reporting a success to
our sender. If that happens, either one
or both of the receivers may never get
the message. In the second case, we'll
take a long time to return a success to
the sender, which is bad user
experience. We want to be able to
quickly report a success message to the
sender, but then asynchronously ensure
that all interested parties eventually
receive the message. For this to happen,
the sender needs to publish the message
to a durable location. For example, we
can persist our message to Kafka and
return a successful result to the sender
as soon as it gets there. However, there
are still complications here. What if
one of the receiver devices is offline?
It needs to get its missed messages when
it comes back up. To facilitate this, we
can just sync this message to our
messages table. When the receiver comes
back up, it can pull messages that it
missed from the messages database. Oh,
wait. This database is actually huge and
we're adding 20 terabytes per day. How
can we partition it so that our message
receiver only has to fetch missed
messages from one shard? To be honest,
there's not really a good way of doing
it because many people are in each group
chat and all users are in a bunch of
different group chats. We can't send
each message to just one shard so that
all reads are super efficient. After
horizontally scaling our table, these
missed message queries become massive
scatter gather queries and are
bottlenecked by the latency of the
slowest shard. We don't want that. To
speed this up, we need to put all
messages that a given user is interested
in onto the same shard. We can
accomplish this with fan out. This
should start to look really similar to
our newsfeed problem from last episode.
Now, when a user wants to fetch their
historic messages after coming back
online, they can just pull the database
for messages since the time stamp of the
one they last received. Up to this
point, we've totally glossed over how we
actually route messages to a given user.
Since we have all these servers actively
maintaining connections to users, we'd
need to keep a mapping of that
somewhere. Every time one of these
servers goes down or one of these
clients disconnects and reconnects to a
different server, we'd need to take note
of this. That's actually kind of a pain
in the ass. Much like my ex-girlfriend,
we now have two different flows for live
messages and historic messages, and they
don't really work all that well with one
another. Actually, we already have a
component that gracefully handles
mapping users to a single node in a
fault tolerant manner. That is the
distributed database. Instead of relying
on client devices maintaining a
persistent connection to a server, they
can just pull their shard of the
database on an interval. I'll call the
table containing the inbox of messages
for each user. The user messages table.
One thing to note is we probably only
want this user messages table to hold
recently received messages per user.
Otherwise, it's going to really balloon
in size. We should probably have a
separate messages table which is going
to be our source of truth. To accomplish
this, we can first write to the messages
table. From there, we can use change
data capture to pipe these incoming
changes into Kafka. This helps us avoid
partial failure scenarios where only one
of the messages database or Kafka
receives the incoming payload. Let's
talk more about our user messages table.
Simply put, this one is going to store
the messages of all the group chats that
a user is in. We can cap the size for
each user by running an occasional query
to clean all but the last few messages
in each group chat. From there, if a
user is scrolling up very far in a
particular chat to get historic
messages, they can just access those
from the normal messages table. We can
partition that one by chat ID so that
accessing messages for a single chat is
speedy. We'll partition our user
messages table by the receiving user ID
so that all messages in a user's inbox
are on the same shard. The first thing
that we want to ensure for this table is
that message insertions to this table
are item potent. We can guarantee this
by using the messages unique ID as our
sort key. That being said, we also want
to allow clients to very quickly fetch
all the messages since the last one that
they've read. If a client device caches
the latest timestamp across all received
messages, they can ask the database for
messages since then. We can accomplish
our goal here by adding a local
secondary index on the timestamp that
the database received the message.
Notice how I'm using the database
receive timestamp as opposed to the
message creation timestamp. This is
because we're receiving messages from
many different servers and many
different chats. So they may not come in
proper order of message creation
timestamp. Then when polling, we'd
permanently miss querying late arriving
messages. Since this is just a local
index, it isn't very expensive to
maintain it. At its core, this problem
is almost identical to the newsfeed
problem. I'll quickly draw out some
parallels. Submitting a message is very
similar to creating a tweet. We want to
be able to fetch messages by chat ID.
So, we'll first persist the message to a
messages table that is sharted
accordingly. Similarly, being in a group
chat is almost comparable to following
the tweets of all the group chat
members. To add someone to the group
chat, we'll just add a row to the chat
members table. The next aspect of the
problem that we'll cover here builds
upon the deep dive section in our prior
video. We know that when a message comes
in, we need to fan it out to the one
database row per group chat member. In
order to do so, we can use change data
capture. This will allow us to take all
incoming messages and place them into a
Kafka stream. This can be done pretty
easily with Debeesium. Recall that we're
persisting 1 million messages per
second, each of which is 200 bytes in
size. To persist 200 megabytes per
second of messages here, we'll certainly
need a few partitions of the change data
capture topic for our messages table.
When a Kafka consumer receives the
message, it must first figure out all
the users in the group chat. In theory,
fetching this from the chat members
database isn't too expensive, though it
does add yet another network hop to our
critical path of handling messages.
Instead, we could actually pre-cache the
members of all group chats in each
consumer. We can do this by subscribing
to a change data capture feed from our
chat members table. However, the full
size of the chat members table is over a
terabyte. What if we don't want to cache
that whole thing? What we can do instead
is use a co-artition join. This way, the
Kafka consumer that handles all messages
for a subset of chats will only cache
the chat members for that subset. We can
do this by partitioning our chat members
and messages change data feeds by the
chat ID. As long as both of these topics
have the same number of partitions, a
consumer that subscribes to the
corresponding partitions of both topics
will handle all the data for the same
subset of chats. A tool that can help us
do this fairly easily is Kafka streams.
Like Kafka consumer groups, Kafka
streams can support at least once
processing across many different
consumer nodes. It also makes sure that
we can easily recover any cache state in
the event of a component failure. In our
case, we've been caching the mapping of
each chat ID to the users in it. If a
consumer fails, we'd like to be able to
easily recover that state on another
node. After our Kafka consumers figure
out which users are in this chat, they
can write a database row for every
single receiving user. In our case, we
want to ensure that these writes are
parallelized as much as possible in
order to achieve maximum throughput. A
user's device can now pull for unread
chat messages. Even though the messages
are coming in a different order than
they'll be displayed on the client
device, there shouldn't be too many of
them at a time, and we can just sort
them accordingly, either on the server
or on the client device itself. As a
user scrolls up in history in a
particular chat, they'll need to fetch
more messages. They can do so by just
hitting the normal messages table. Since
chats are limited in their number of
members, we shouldn't have to worry
about hotspots when reading or writing
to this table. If any of the prior
information didn't make sense here, I'd
highly encourage watching the newsfeed
videos over the last 2 weeks. Anyways,
let's move on to today's deep dive. This
is mainly going to center around a race
condition to do with change data
capture. We'll also have a small section
on using our database to provide
timestamps for ordering messages in the
user messages table. Let's imagine I'm
in a group chat with someone I don't
like, for example, Donald Trump, and I
want to say something mean about him. I
remove him and I send a message
commenting on his small hands. What
could happen is that my message gets to
the Kafka consumer before the fact that
I removed Donald from the chat. In this
case, he'll actually see my message.
Let's talk about how we could prevent
this. We know that the unfollow occurs
before the chat message. Since they're
both sent from the same client, the
client itself can actually write the
timestamp of the unfollow operation into
the message itself. In our stream
consumer, we can actually check the
maximum update timestamp that we've seen
associated with the chat numbers. If
it's not sufficiently up to date with
the timestamp in the message, then we
need to pull the database for conclusive
results. Notably, this type of thing
does not work if you just have Messenger
open on your phone and laptop and do the
operations on different devices. there's
simply no way to coordinate them. That
being said, if we did have some way of
giving an accurate timestamp to every
single database, write regardless of the
client that it comes from, we could do a
similar process like we did above by
checking that our chat members
information is as upto-date as our
message creation timestamp. This is
because we know our message creation
timestamp is greater than the unfollow
operation timestamp. This is actually
the concept behind Google Zanzibar. They
use Google true time to assign every
event a globally linearizable time
stamp. That way for an incoming event
they can check for all known security
permissions created before its time
stamp. Let's now talk a little bit more
about our design which uses database
assigned timestamps. Recall that in our
user messages table, a user needs to be
able to efficiently query for unseen
messages. We accomplish this by using
the timestamp that the database received
each message since it is strictly
increasing. However, this assumption
isn't fully true. If the node that's
assigning our timestamps goes down and
the new node assigning timestamps has a
clock that is behind the original, it
may assign too old a time stamp to some
incoming messages. When the client
pulls, it won't look back far enough in
order to see those new messages. As far
as I can tell, there are a couple of
solutions here. On the failover, the new
leader could wait until its local clock
time surpasses that of its latest scene
message. This could potentially result
in longer failover times. Another
solution here would be to keep track of
the database timestamp and the identity
of the node that assigned them. In that
case, if a new leader pops up, we'll
realize that we have to start querying
its timestamps from the beginning of
time and keep track of a max time stamp
for all leaders on the client. Well
guys, I certainly hope that you enjoyed
this video. It was definitely a fun one
for me to make. Um, I think if people
watch this in isolation, a lot of you
guys might not love it very much because
frankly, it's quite confusing. Like I've
said a lot here that makes many
assumptions that you've been watching
these videos sequentially. And uh I hope
people are actually doing that. Like I'm
really going to keep this 3.0 series to
probably like 10 to maybe 15 videos at
most. And my hope is that you know just
by covering all the super popular design
patterns, we can actually build up in a
way that you know it helps to watch the
prior video before going on to the next
one. Because otherwise I'm just covering
a bunch of redundant stuff. like this
problem is very very similar to the
newsfeed, but kind of the main value of
doing a problem like this is pattern
recognition of being like, "Oh, wait a
second. This is yet another fan out
problem. This one, the notification
service, there are a few of them like
this." Uh, if you can recognize them as
you're going through it in an interview,
then you can come up with a solution
really, really quickly. Anyways guys, I
hope you enjoyed this video and I'm
looking forward to the next